Jeff and Larry words cannot convey how
delighted I truly am to do just that Jon
Bernthal is hot it's true and if like me
you might way to crawl around mud and
talking acropole listen you'll be able
to do very soon with this bata
announcement Ghost Recon grade boy it's
only by working as a team that you can
rise
[Music]
hello ghost and Xbox fans I'm Jon
Bernthal I play cold Walker in Ghost
Recon break point we're putting the
finishing touches on Aurora so feel free
to download the beta from September 26
September 29 hope you enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
see you there ghosts
[Music]
and you will see me there Jon Bernthal
you can pre-order the beta right now so
preload the beta excuse me it's ready to
go on September 26 now I live like like
one very simple life rule and it is do
whatever mr. Bernthal tells me to which
is why I'm especially excited to see
what's coming next
Jon Bernthal portrays the game's villain
wanted to share some of his approach
with everyone here so please enjoy this
punishing look at breakpoints cold
Walker you get it does he play The
Punisher to get it I'm a wolf raised to
be the Alpha trying to follow
alas the Beast can't be tamed that
easily
Walker he's grown deeply disillusioned
with the sort of state of affairs with
the ghosts he thinks that their moral
compass and their set of rules are
holding them back and keeping them from
attaining the mission at hand I think he
develops this new code that's born out
of his frustration born out of his anger
born out of his the pain for the loss of
the men that have have died under his
watch and I think what he thinks it's
because of these these rules so he's
developed this new philosophy and he's
got this new band of soldiers that are
behind him and look I know he's looked
at as the antagonist of the game but you
know it's it's my job not to judge him
it's my job to empathize with him and
believe in him you know with Emil being
on set the entire time you know he's
Green Beret this project from the
beginning had a real dedication towards
authenticity he had a really specific
sort of way that not just how a coal
moved and handled his weapon and
protocol but but also for mindset and I
think that's really what's what's kind
of most important and I think anytime
you get the honor of portraying a vet
it's it's a huge responsibility
[Music]
you know this kind of process with mocap
is you have to have one flawless take
there's no place to hide there's cameras
everywhere I come from the theater so I
really dig that you rehearse it to get
it perfect
I think it just brings everybody's game
up and I really enjoyed that part of the
process I was really humbled by how much
this game means to the people that are
making it I knew from the second I got
there just how important this was to
them there's no different from you know
a great television show a great movie
when you're following a filmmaker and
you're following a group of artists who
are absolutely committed to doing their
best that's that's what drives me 100%
but do think law I took this island and
bought tooth and claw I will rule it
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
now we've still got plenty of awesome
games coming up for you guys including a
look at Daisy's new Livonia expansion a
pub crawl through hell an after party
and advanced info on excellent